المترجم: Aya AlAjjan
المدقّق: Ayman Mahmoud
(هذا مكعب)
(يمكنني وضع ما أريد في داخله)
(وهذه ورقة)
(لا يمكنني وضع أي شيء فيها)
(لأن هذا ثلاثي الأبعاد، وهذه ثنائية البعد)
(وتعليمنا يشبه تماماً هذه الورقة)
(ألم تتساءلوا عن سبب تحدثي بالانكليزية؟)
ألم تتساءلوا عن سبب تحدثي بالانكليزية؟
سمعت هذه المقولة من أستاذ أمريكي،
قال بأن التعليم لدينا يشبه هذه الورقة.
منذ أن سمعتها حين كت صغيرة بقيت أتساءل:
إذن ماهو المكعب؟
أنا حالياً في الصف الحادي عشر
ودرست في إحدى عشرة مدرسة؛
-ابن بطوطة المدارس-
وما زلت أبحث عن الجواب.
إذا ألقينا نظرة على هذه الأحداث --
الاحتلال والحروب العالمية،
تبدُّل البورصة يومياً في كل ثانية،
ظهور طبخة جديدة في كل يوم،
ومرض جديد كل يوم بحاجة للعلاج،
العالم في تغيّر مستمر،
والعلم في توسع مستمر،
أما التعليم فهو باقٍ على حاله.
أصبح عادةً من العادات والتقاليد
التي تتوارثها الأجيال
من جيل إلى جيل بقي نفسه.
أريد أن أسألكم لتجيبوا برفع اليد؛
من اجتاز اختبار الثانوية منذ
أكثر من عشرة سنين؟
-لا، لن ننتقص منكم-
من اجتاز الثانوية منذ أقل
من عشرة سنين؟
جميل، ارتفع العدد.
ما وجدته أن الثانوية العامة
منذ أيام الأزل وحتى الآن
ما زالت نفسها، وما زال
الكلام الذي يقال عنها نفسه؛
"فيلم رعب"، "لا تبدع الآن
والتزم بما أمامك من مقرر فقط"
أن تغيّر 0.3 من العلامة
مستقبل وحياة الطالب،
هذا بحد ذاته شيء كافٍ لجعلها فيلم
رعب يخيف أكثر من The Conjuring
وتستحق كلمةً أطول، لو كنت
أملك الوقت لأكملتها لكم.
جملة الرعب التي يقولها الأساتذة
والجيرةُ والأقرباء؛
"لطالما كان هناك طلاب مجدّون في الثانوية
ساء حظهم ودرسوا الفنون"
لمَ؟ مما تشكي الفنون؟
لأن العادة جرت هكذا ..
لأن الأنظمة التعليمية
تركز على شيء واحد فقط،
وهو القدرة الأكاديمية أي القدرة على الحفظ
والدراسة والذكاء والتطبيقات بشكل عام.
يكمن السبب إذا عدنا قليلاً
في التاريخ إلى الوراء
لنجد الحل هناك،
لأن أول نظام تعليمي حقيقي قام
في القرن التاسع عشر على أمرين أساسين:
الأول هو الموافقة لاحتياجات التصنيع،
والثاني هو القدرة الأكاديمية؛
القدرة على الحفظ والدراسة
كمحور مكمل.
حالياً، طغت القدرة الأكاديمية
على الموضوع ككل،
أما الموافقة لاحتياجات التصنيع فأين هي؟
ما زالت موجودة أجل لكن
حسب مفهوم التصنيع القديم،
والتي ندرس لأجلها الرياضيات نفسها
والفيزياء نفسها منذ زمن.
أتسألون أنفسكم ما هو المفهوم
الحديث؟ وتنتظرون الإجابة مني؟
هو ذاته المكعب الذي تحدث
عنه الأستاذ الأمريكي.
إذا بحثنا في Google عن
آلاف العناوين التي سنجدها
في إصلاح التعليم، لكنني لم أجد جوابي.
وحاولت أيضاً أن أسأل ذلك
الأستاذ فلم أستطع الحصول
على إجابة لأنه أيضاً توفى.
رحمه الله، لم يستطع إتمام النظام،
لكنني أسميت هذا النظام
"نظام التعليم ثلاثي الأبعاد" CAS
C) Creation) من الإبداع،
A) Action) التواصل الاجتماعي،
S) Service) والتي هي خدمة المجتمع.
هو نظام تعليمي ثلاثي الأبعاد
يرتكز على التخلص من مقت العلوم
وكثافة المواد، وصولاً للخلق
والإبداع والخدمة،
بمعنى أن الطالب الاجتماعي يُعامل
بمثل معاملة الطالب المجتهد
ومعاملة الطالب الخدوم
الذي يفيد مجتمعه، والطالب المبدع.
نظام تعليمي يعامل المجتمع على أساس
احتياجاته، والطالب على أساس ملكاته.
ما رأيكم؟ أتحبون الدراسة بمثل هكذا نظام؟
كلامٌ عالي الثقة صحيح؟
صممت بنفسي مخططاً للنظام
التعليمي الذي يجب وجوده
وقررت أن أقدمه لوزارة التربية
وأصبح في لجنة تعديل المناهج.
كانت خطوة جريئة فقالوا لي
تمهلي أين تذهبين بفكرك!
صعبٌ على الوزارة أن تطبق
هكذا مقررات تبعاً لبعض الظروف،
لكنني أستطيع تعميم هذه
التجربة على من حولي.
لطالما كانت عائلتي داعمةً لي بشدة.
حين كان عمري تسع سنوات،
كانت أمي تشتري لي دفتراً
لأخبرها بكل ما حصل لي
في نهاري عن طريق الرسم،
ودفتراً آخر لأكتب فيه
رأيي بمنتقدات التعليم،
ومنتقداتي للمدرسة، وعن رأيي بالتعديلات،
ورأيي بالوزارة ورأيي بكل شيء؛
كنت أشعر وكأنني وزير التربية بذاته.
خلق هذا الشعور فيّ مسؤوليةً كبيرة جداً،
-لا يسألْني أحدٌ عن هذا الدفتر
لأن والدتي تحتفظ فيه في أحد الخزائن
وتعرف بأني لن أفهم كتابة خط يدي-
المهم، أني الآن أملك ذات
الدفتر لريادة الأعمال،
للبرمجة، والأعمال التطوعية،
للرسم والامتحانات --
وبذكر الامتحانات، من يتخيل حياته دونها؟
من المستحيل أن نتخيلها..
في الصف الثامن، وبصفتي
ابن بطوطة المدارس،
سافرت إلى لبنان،
وكانت المدرسة التي ارتدتُها
رائعة جداً ومليئة بالنشاطات،
لكن كوني لست مواطنةً لبنانية،
لم يحق لي المشاركة في أيٍّ منها،
لكني لم أفكر ذلك، لم أشأ تحصيل
العلامات العليا في لبنان والعودة إلى هنا،
بل كنت أود تمثيل حمص في سوريا،
كنت أريد تمثيلها في كل الجوانب،
في الرسم، في الواقع الذي تعيشه،
من الناحية الاجتماعية،
ومن جميع النواحي،
أرغب بتمثيلها بالشعب الموجود أمامنا.
فأصبحت بالصدفة أكتب
المسرحيات، وأقيم المعارض،
وأمثل في المسرحيات وأكتب الشعر وألقيه.
بالصدفة أصبحت أريد فعل كل شيء.
نتيجةً للبصمة التي تركتها
في المدرسة، قررت الإدارة
أن تعفيني من التقدم لجميع الامتحانات.
(تصفيق)
ربما لم تسمعوا بكل هذه الضجة
لأننا ما زلنا في المنهج السوري،
وما زلنا ندرس كتاب العلوم ذا 300 صفحة،
وكتاب الرياضيات ذا 400 صفحة،
الجبر، الهندسة، التحليل
وكتابٌ أول وكتابٌ ثانٍ،
لم تسمعوا بهذه الضجة؛
منهج كثيف بالرغم من عظم
أهميته إلا أنه كثيف جداً.
أود أن أسأل، من مهندس المدنية الذي
ما زال يتذكر ماهو جهاز التنفس لدى الصرصور؟
أو من يتذكر ما هو مرض الألفا تلاسيميا؟
هناك من يتذكر وأوجه تحياتي له؛
أو من الطبيب الذي يتذكر إلى
الأن ما تعريف الحث النهري؟
من يتذكرُ أرسل حقاً تحياتي
له لأنه شيء صعب،
في النهاية، كل شخص مشى بحسب اختصاصه،
وتخلصت الذاكرة من كل ما لا يلزمها،
وأصبحت تستخدم فقط ما يلزمها.
كثافة المنهاج هي عائق كبير حقاً؛
عائق أمام تطبيق نظام CAS،
كيف نتخلص منها إذن؟
نتخلص منها من أنفسنا دون أن ننتظر أحداً.
أول خطوة هي تحديد الاختصاص بالشكل الصحيح،
أي أنني أحدد اختصاصي
وفقاً لثلاثة أشياء معاً:
الأولى هي القدرة،
الثانية هي الرغبة بالمواد،
والثالثة هي المواد ذاتها التي أدرسها.
ومن ناحية أخرى علي أن
أنظر إلى المواد التعليمية
وكأنني إن لم أختر هذا الاختصاص
فسينقص شيء من العالم،
أي يجب أن أنظر إلى كل مادة
تعليمية بنظرة نظام CAS؛
كيف يمكن أن أفكر بها خارج الصندوق،
كيف تصب في مجال التواصل الاجتماعي،
وكيف تصب في خدمة المجتمع.
إذا نظرت هكذا إلى المواد التعليمية
ستكون الدنيا بخير.
النقطة الثالثة هي أن ننظر إلى
الموضوع بنظرة أينشتاين.
ماذا يعني ذلك؟ ما الذي استحضر سيرته؟
المهم، كان أينشتاين جالساً مع رفاقه مرة --
لا أعرف حتى إن كان يملك أصدقاءً
لكنني سمعت بالقصة هكذا --
وكان يتحدث عن سرعة صوته فسألوه:
كم سرعة صوتك الآن؟
فسرح في فكره، -إذا سألتموني
كم سرعة صوتي فلن أعرفها-
هل يعرف أحدكم سرعة صوتي أثناء حديثي؟
هل يعرف أحدكم؟ صعبٌ ذلك.
قلنا لنذهب --
(ضحك)
لذلك قلنا لنسأل أينشتاين،
فسألناه وأخذ يفكر فقال:
أنا لا أعلم!
مهمتي إبداع المعلومة وليس حفظها،
أي أنه يوجد ناسٌ مجتهدون
أكثر من أيشنتاين ذاته إنما بالحفظ،
وكلٌّ منهم مشى بحسب اختصاصه.
النقطة الأخيرة لكم كجمهور،
أن يكون لديكم نية ليست فقط في تجريب
نظام تعليمي قد يوجد في المستقبل،
بل أن نعيش حياةً ثلاثية الأبعاد،
تكونون أنتم فيها البعد الرابع.
هل أنتم مستعدون لصنع التطابق؟
?Are you ready to make the match
هل سيصبح التعليم قوةً صانعةً
للسلام والمستقبل الدائم؟
لن أختم بالأنكليزية لأن
النهاية ليست أجنبية،
والحل ليس غريباً علينا؛
هو واقع تعليم عربي ثلاثي الأبعاد
بإمكانه الانطلاق من هذه المنصة.
كل هذه الفعاليات، والمنصة التي أطلقناها
وكل الأشغال والدراسات
التي نقوم بها هي من أجل المستقبل،
ومن أجل تغيير المستقبل،
والدفعة التي تتخرج الآن تتفاعد في 2060.
هل سيكون المستقبل كما نخطط له؟
هل سنعيش على كرة أرضية أم دائرة أرضية؟
شكراً.
(تصفيق)